can you explain what licensing footage
is absolutely well uh as part of my
career I've uh I shoot stock footage
I've shoot documentaries travel
Adventure programs and movies so there's
a variety of possible income streams uh
filmmaker can explore for me that's what
I've uh been doing for these decades so
for licensing of stock shots which I've
uh God I've got so many thousands of
stock shots what you do is you co
through all the footage that you shoot
on assignment in a particular country
you kind of edit that down to maybe a
top thousand shots from all this hours
of footage you shot and then you put it
on a real digital file and then you
license it to uh different companies uh
National Geographic represents thousands
of my shots action shots motion shots uh
I don't shoot Stills you could probably
do frame grabs these days from uh 6K 8K
footage and they could look great right
but it's all been motion shots I've
licensed over time to different
companies uh you know so there's there's
paon five there's so many different
companies out there Getty and what you
do is you uh sign a contract with them
uh it's can be Perpetual I mean it can
be an automatic renewing thing you can
limit it to 5 years uh it's up to you uh
usually I just let it go for in perpet
it because there's no reason not to if
you're getting a check and then you can
try to renegotiate sometimes the uh the
terms of uh of your contract or how much
you're getting per shot stock footage
though has not been as profitable for me
anyway as it was uh in the 9s and the
early
2000s and that's because there are just
so many more people now shooting uh
really high res shots with
iPhones and uh where it used to be the
case where you'd have to spend more
money for uh good equipment good uh good
gear that you could uh not have to uh
compete with uh so many millions of
other people shooting how many we're in
a selfie generation so people shooting
reams of shots and and some of these
people are now marketing it through paon
five for very small amount of
money sometimes just $35 a shot it used
to be $1,500 a shot for certain things
that you would shoot in different
countries that were a little bit more
unusual or rare to shoot but now it's
different in the last 10 years I've
noticed a decline of uh of income from
the stock footage sales so I don't
normally recommend people do that but uh
it just depends on you know how
aggressive you are at marketing your
your library and your shots but uh you
can have as many deals as you want with
different companies you don't have to be
exclusive to Nat Geo or to Getty or to
any of these others you can create a
whole library of shots thousands of
shots and offer it to different stock
footage libraries did you adopt Drone
footage right away I know that's
something that's maybe a little more
rare than these selfies or yes Drone
footage as every filmmaker knows has
changed the entire complexion of uh film
making the entire let's say Tools in
your toolkit that you can bring uh to
your movie uh it used to be of course
when I was uh starting out early on it
would be shooting from planes from
helicopters probably not from balloons
but at least helicopters now that that
was very expensive to do you know it was
uh $1,500 an hour to shoot from a
helicopter or a plane and then you'd
have to have specialized stabilizing
gear as well inside the plane they take
a door off and you have to go through
this entire riger Moll to do this and uh
so those were very selective shots and
you couldn't afford it often for your
shows depends on your budget but now of
course drones are just taken for granted
now it's uh they're so cheap to get some
of them are are still very good and
still very cheap so it's it's a matter
of uh almost every I think I can't
really think of any film now that I
would uh want to do or any movie that
would not incorporate drone shots
especially if they take place in the
international settings where we always
shoot because that's part of uh what
we're doing is is trying to transport
the viewer and the audience to Egypt to
Thailand to Zanzibar to Antarctica
whatever you're doing you need to bring
them in to the the general setting it
used to be you know called the uh the
master shot and now a master shot could
be coming in over Cairo and then coming
into the
marketplace uh going over the pyramids
or going you know over icebergs in
Antarctica it's just an expected part of
your toolkit now to bring those into
play and so uh again depends on the
country and uh their permits like I said
Egypt it's illegal but uh most countries
you can uh bring a drone into and shoot
and even in Egypt you can hire a
government appointed uh production
company to do drone shots for you it's
just more money so but even here in La I
think that you couldn't just necessarily
go to downtown LA and find a landmark a
good point do a drone and that's uh
let's talk about accessibility of of
drones and let's say you're you're going
to Europe you're going to Paris and you
wanted to get some drone shots well
that's not going to be that easy I think
what I was referring to before are
usually in uh desert Landscapes or over
rivers or over certain uh big
geographical sites mountains or
Foothills and mountains and th those
sorts of things in the country that's
pretty easy you can do that
but in in most country except for China
again we have to have all these caveats
if it's a communist country or something
like that those are very tightly
controlled you can't usually shoot a uh
with a drone in a communist country
that's pretty tricky but a lot of
countries dozens and dozens of them you
can uh bring in a drone and do that but
yeah like in Downtown LA or virtually
any city in the US or even a town there
are definitely laws on the books you
can't just fly a drone through a
downtown LA without special permission
and there's like Pilots license for
drones and so on but uh again like a lot
of the countries I I go to they're uh
the laws are a little bit uh gray and so
sometimes you just uh take the chance
and
negotiate when when that's uh if
somebody comes up with her hand
out what types of shots are most
marketable if you are to license
the footage later on very good question
the sense of uh what is uh what are the
most popular shots being
licensed uh for me since I only focus on
uh International shots uh from the
ground from the sea drone shots things
like that that only represents 5 to 10%
of the marketplace 90% I understand from
uh other filmmaker friends who focus on
just doing drone shots and stock footage
shots in the US 90% of the demand is for
domestic subject matter not
International isn't that interesting I
always thought that that would be a
higher percentage there'd be more demand
for shots from uh Rome or wherever you
know but uh that's not the case it has
more to do with more practical things
because a lot of times um stock shots
are used for ads you know supplemental
shots of uh people working in offices or
a product they're trying to sell
domestically so they just need more uh
uh readily uh recognizable shots for
advertising and uh if it's for
documentar sometimes producers want
documentary shots of something that they
can't easily get but still 90% of uh the
shots that you might be shooting you
might as well Focus mostly on domestic
based themes that's where most of the
money
is interestingly enough surprising yeah
isn't it yeah I would think that uh the
more unusual shots of uh other countries
would be more popular but that's not
really the case so I found that to be
interesting
too so the licensing terms you kind of
talked about you said it depends it can
be in perpetuity yes it can be in
perpetuity or you can just limit it to
five years or whatever you want to
negotiate often they're fairly
flexible okay but they also do well I
didn't mention is they usually want to
also with stock footage shots uh if
you're doing that for part of your
income as a filmmaker you want to be
sure you have a u sort of provenance
line of custody on that uh model
releases if you're uh shooting anything
to do with people's faces in a crowd or
in a market or wherever in a business
setting wherever you're shooting
nationally or internationally you have
to get that model license uh have them
sign off and pay them a dollar whatever
it is you know it's it's a nominal thing
most people don't really care uh
although sometimes when you bring out a
model license they kind of go wait a
second are you going to be making a lot
of money on this it almost draws more
question to what you're doing but
generally speaking and actually
specifically you do want to get um some
kind of model release photography
release from every subject that is seen
in the frame
for there's no exact uh formula for this
but at least if you can recognize a
person essentially that would mean like
2 seconds if they're passing by you
better get their permission and I've
noticed that with stock footage
companies now they're getting much more
stringent on on requiring permits uh not
permits but uh permission from your
subjects didn't used to be that way uh
10 20 30 years ago but now it's more
stringent and even if you photograph say
the Eiffel Tower with their light show
they have every night that's now
copyrighted that light show and you
can't actually sell a shot of the Eiffel
Tower at night without having the
permission of whoever designed the light
show isn't that
interesting but think about how many
millions of shots are are done by people
uh every year right of the Eiffel Tower
at night but it's just becoming you more
um regimented I suppose as far as
getting uh permits and
permissions